for the latest on Nick Cannon after his
controversial exit from America's Got
Talent
only we went straight to the source
Kevin Frazier scored an exclusive in New
York with Nick and frankly everybody
wants to know what is Nick thinking cuff
Nancy it really was a shocking turn of
events because hosting AGT seems like a
dream gig but let me say this I have
known Nick for a long time and there
always is some kind of method to what
people may call is madness why leave
America's Got town it seems like a dream
job why leave that job because it's a
job and people
I'm not defined by a job they get caught
in a sense right you should be happy to
be here or you wee it is the dream job
things like this don't come along
everyone but things like that don't
define me
Nick's sticking to his principles
walking away from the show he's hosted
for eight seasons after he says NBC
executives threatened to fire him for
making jokes like this one on his
Showtime comedy special
I apologize white people we over here
talking about players and stuff and you
think this is America's Got Talent when
people start to put restraints on my
creativity as an artist I just have to
stand on my square and stand for
something if money is isn't one of the
things that moves me or inspires me I
love it I embrace it the way everyone
else does wonderful planning but uh I
don't make decisions based off of it so
so it wasn't an emotional decision no
not at all everything I do is calculated
did they threaten to fire you they did
you know I think that that's very
apparent but I never want to play the
victim and I never want to point fingers
or oh I felt like I was mistreated I
wish everyone the best so no hard
feelings on his end but what does he
think about rumors that actor Brandon
Michael Smith could be his AGT
replacement we're a community we got a
look to build one another up so when you
see somebody else get an opportunity all
you can do a salute i sat down with Nick
in Times Square as he was prepping to go
live for MTV's wild and out a show he
created that's now in its ninth season
he's hosting a Talent Search for the
next cast member he's also got a movie
out soon and
to make music bullets really got people
talking this wild youtube video blog
that left some worry he was coming
unhinged people saw that vlog and they
said what's going on with now all right
enough with the parlor tricks it's so
funny because people see that vlogging
like oh what's wrong with it was like
it's I'm an artist and I get excited
when people don't understand something
because I always say first they call you
crazy then second ass how did you do it
Nick is also passionate about his family
he just welcomed his third child a boy
with ex-girlfriend Brittany Bell
he's also co-parenting his twins with
ex-wife Mariah Carey how do you and
Mirai work it out cuz it seems like it's
a really it is a very good relationship
it but it's it's comical its humorous to
me the way the world perceives myself
and Mariah in the way that we actually
live er when we first met but we had
conversations of like what if this
didn't work out how would we operate I
would never have a bad thing a negative
thing to say about her and everything
that she's built even with our children
she's the magnificent mother see how
happy they are you can see that they're
they're loved unconditionally and at the
end of the day that's not number one
priority
[Music]